okay wir haben euch was zum Song sag nix
es ist für die Kleine ist ganz vergessen
dass dieser madlwirt die Grünen
was ist das ist die Mitgliedschaft für
ein FC Bayern für den kleinen Georg
Junior über Georg ich bin noch ein
Sechziger
ich bin jetzt schwanger
wo es mir sagen wollten
mir fehlen demnächst für drei Monate
nach Asien ja wir wollten eine kleine
Auszeit nehmen von
hier
denkt sie ein einziges Mal an uns wie
bitte ja alle anderen in unserem Alter
haben schon Enkel ja genauso gut
bis 60 Champions League gewinnt die
Sophie von die Steiners die hat sogar
das Haus wie alle anderen Frührentner
auch ich habe es immer schon gesagt du
hättest mit dem martinssamblem sein der
Martin das war der Vorgänger Horst ja
mit dem Martin hättest Du mindestens
schon drei Kinder ja und der Martin
hätte noch mit Sicherheit viel mehr
Kinder mit den ganzen anderen Weiber mit
denen eine beschissen hat und es wurde
mit dem Typen kommt jetzt endlich weg da
na gut dann machen wir eben ein neues
Familienbild ja kurz vor mir aus aber er
steht am Rand dass man zur Not
wegschneiden kann wenn es wieder mal
wieder nichts wird so jetzt ist aber mal
gut
es tut mir leid Schatzi du weißt ich
liebe dich aber das mit deinen Eltern
das
geht nicht genau das meine
Blutdrucktabletten
mal Danke ich erzähle geschafft mit dem
Schluss zu machen der hat das so einen
Hundeblick Schatzi komm nicht
das vorstellen mit der rolls-soße drei
Monate in Asien danke
gibt
von dem
oh hallo wie heißt der marzl 32 Marcel
Horster